PROFESSOR: So welcome to our
Massive Open Online Course,
10.S95x, Physics of
COVID-19 Transmission.
The course is organized
into five chapters. First,
transfer of
respiratory pathogens,
where we will learn about how
viral and bacterial diseases
are transmitted through the air
through aerosol and other types
of droplets.
In the next chapter,
part two, we
will study airborne transmission
in a well-mixed room.
We'll analyze the
fluid mechanics
of droplet transfer between
individuals breathing
the same air in a room.
And then in the next chapter,
we will describe basic models
in the field of epidemiology
to describe the spread
and transfer of disease.
In the next chapter, 4, we will
integrate the disease modeling
with airborne transmission to
arrive at a safety guideline
to limit the indoor airborne
transmission of COVID-19.
And we will apply it to
COVID-19 through analysis
of various spreading events.
And then finally,
in Chapter 5, we
will go beyond the
well-mixed room
to discuss the fluid
mechanics of ventilation
and thermal flows
and respiratory flows
and understand the
limitations and extensions
of the analysis leading
to the safety guideline.